elle veut devenir l'incubateur
d'entreprises du sud-yvelines la
fabrique a organisé le 16 octobre
dernier un concours pour les créateurs
d'entreprises à la bergerie nationale de
rambouillet objectif pour les candidats
faire un pitch en 90 secondes de leur
projet et répondre aux questions du jury
pendant 10 minutes
sept porteurs de projets sur dix ont été
sélectionnés pour participer au concours
une réussite pour la fabrique les
compétences humaines elles sont là les
ressources sont là les les compétences
techniques logistiques matériel aussi
voilà il manque
il manquait plus je dirais qu un
incubateur la fabrique joue ce rôle
d'incubateur sur le territoire est là
pour donc accompagner les porteurs de
projets et être lieu ressource également
le jury composé de quatre chefs
d'entreprise aguerris devait donc noter
chaque bleach en fonction de plusieurs
critères comme la faisabilité ou la
crédibilité
le lauréat donc du prix du jury se voit
offrir une séance d'accompagnement pour
conforter son
son business plan ou conforter son son
plan de communication et le jury a en
plus
décidé que chacun d'entre nous passions
un petit peu de temps avec le lauréat
pour regarder d'un oeil
on va dire à experts mais en tout cas un
peu plus aguerri
le business plan et le plan
communication ceux qui vont bénéficier
de ses conseils c'est arnaud et sa femme
porteurs du projet arlos koffi
leur but être artisan torréfacteur à
rambouillet en envoyant leurs canaux de
distribution comme un profit trucks un
magasin de café ambulant c'est forcément
un plus ce d'être accompagné par des
gens de société qui fonctionne et qui
est qui sont en plus représentées à
rambouillet s'est aussi bien pour le
réseau que pour la réussite direct delà
de la société le lancement d'ares l'os
koffi est prévue pour février prochain
en plus du prix du jury la future
société a déjà des contacts avec de
potentiels clients